yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Pisco gambit from canada pisco
where's that this is like fish or
something okay and camp here taking in
queen bee three always was quite
promising for white but recently they
devised a consequence 96 and this makes
it hard less attractor yeah this is not
as promising in comparison but still
very well playable so we'll see what we
get here again fiscal gambit you will
probably take now yeah he does and now
how do you play that I think this is the
start okay but now we have to go back
right okay I can play be five right away
i'm not sure about it I don't think it
can be all that bad at this particular
moment okay now i can take a plane 94
this should be pretty nice Oh black
resin okay I wonder your resignation
when okay a position is dreadful just
blundered t5 yeah those openings they
they look harmless but they they are not
already so let's have a look so yeah
what I was talking about it that this is
the was the traditional mainland until
it was discovered that black can
actually play knight c6 in the slime
after Queen here Bishop e7 leg gets
excellent compensation for the pond sir
I completely hate this for white so
thats not not on but fortunately what
can play this first and then go for this
line where black is supposed to be okay
but still I feel there are some
interesting things to to check yeah him
we went to take you should see files
also possible you 693 and I actually
think we should see five might not be
good here yeah the computer immediately
gives one an edge and this is a bit
annoying you cannot take with the 8th
porn you cannot take with the sea porn
if he does that I can take him that's
really really awful okay it's pretty bad
or you can also i was thinking taking
okay look see once that's not very human
this move okay now in switches i wanted
to do this anyway and it should be great
that this is hanging this is hanging
that's great and tina takes the 94th
already pretty dreadful c6 is hanging
and I see five is given at the best move
oh and now it switches but it's also
pretty bad and there's winning a pool
full porn there okay did not need to
resign but the position is really bad
yeah again this is some this has a
little bit more poison than it initially
looks like ok guys thanks for watching